du bal le Sénat comme vous ne l'avez
jamais entendu
[Musique]
arabesque boiserie toile cette pièce est
un ravissement pour les yeux à votre
avis de quand date sa décoration
un buste montre Marie de Médicis
fondatrice du Palais du Luxembourg au
début du 17e siècle il est anachronique
en effet la reine n'a jamais connu cette
pièce d'or et d'azur qui a été conçue
bien plus tard en son hommage inspiré
des cabinets du XVIIe siècle cette pièce
majestueuse a été dessinée deux siècles
plus tard au 19e siècle elle comprend
une pièce coiffée d'un grand plafond et
une petite galerie séparée par quatre
piliers cadres angulaires
reconstitué à partir d'éléments de décor
originaux cette salle du livre d'or
offre un précieux témoignage de la
richesse des appartements royaux de la
reine de France et de Navarre
si l'illusion est parfaite c'est aussi
grâce au talent de deux architectes
Jean-François chagrin et Thomas pierre
baragué
après la révolution de 1789 les
appartements royaux sont dépouillés
convertis en prison sous la Terreur le
Palais du Luxembourg est dans un état
désastreux lorsqu'il devient en 1795 le
siège du directoire le régime qui
gouverne la France depuis la fin de la
Convention nationale
la somptueuse pièce que vous traversez
n'est alors qu'un salon désaffecté
délabré et moisi pour l'architecte
Jean-François chagrin chargé de faire du
Palais du Luxembourg un palais de
gouvernement le défi est de taille il ne
reste alors de la décoration d'origine
que les lambrises abîmées et des
peintures sur bois noirci par le temps
chaque grain prend soin de protéger ses
vestiges de l'ancien régime en les
stockant dans une réserve sous la
Restauration de 1816 à 1817 son
successeur Thomas pierre baraguer
transforme ce salon pour y abriter le
livre de la péri ce fameux livre d'or
qui donne son nom à cette pièce ce livre
consigne les titres des pères de France
nommé par le roi c'est ici qu'il venait
signer leur désignation l'architecte
Thomas pierre baragais imagine un décor
fastueux il réemploi les ornements
sauvés par Chalgrin et décide d'embellir
la pièce en prélevant dans les réserves
du Louvre des piliers peints et des
boiseries provenant d'un cabinet des
appartements dan d'Autriche la
belle-fille de Marie de Médicis
la reconstitution est très réussie les
lambris dorés les arabesques sur les
piliers peints de Charles Erard les
tapisseries aux couleurs dominantes d'or
et de lapis-lazuli reprennent vie
une salle du 17e siècle plus vrai que
nature vaut ainsi le jour au début du
19e siècle en 1817
l'ensemble sera complétée plus
tardivement encore par des toiles
peintes placées entre les pilastres ces
hautes colonnes plates
quant au livre d'or qui était auparavant
conservé au Sénat il a été versé aux
Archives nationales en 1848
levez les yeux au centre du plafond
l'immense tableau représente la reine
assise sur des nuages et recevant des
mains de la paix un faisceau de flèche
qu'elle s'apprête à nouer c'est le
symbole de la paix signée entre
protestants et catholique la composition
s'intitule Marie de Médicis rétablissant
la paix en France cette commande de la
reine a longtemps été attachée au nom du
peintre Jean Monnier mais le tableau a
récemment été attribué à l'école de
Philippe de Champaigne le tableau
central est encadré d'une série de huit
civils ou prophétesse qui étaient situés
dans l'oratoire de la reine l'auteur de
ces 8 peintures reste inconnues
avant de quitter la salle du livre d'or
prenez un moment pour observer ce petit
buste de bronze ce visage élégant et
serein c'est celui de Marie de Médicis
en 1853 le sculpteur Jules claqueman
modèle en terre cuite un buste de la
reine destiné aux cloître du Luxembourg
il est probable que cette sculpture soit
la transcription en bronze de ce buste
en terre aujourd'hui disparu
l'identité de son sculpteur n'est
toujours pas connue la salle du livre
d'or n'a pas encore livré tous ces
mystères
[Musique]